seulement 36 ans elle vient de donner sa
leçon inaugurale au prestigieux collège
de france économistes brillante elle
préfère s'intéresser à la pauvreté
plutôt qu au capitalisme financier et
elle le fait très concrètement grâce au
laboratoire de recherche qu'elle a créé
om haïti de cambridge voici maintenant
l'invité des cinq dernières minutes et
s'est invité sept esther duflo bonjour
merci vraiment d'être avec nous ici sur
le plateau du 13 heures de france 2 je
le disais en vous présentant vous venez
de donner votre leçon inaugurale au
collège de france qui est très rare
quand on a 36 ans
comment vous l'avez pris est ce que vous
l'avez prix comme une reconnaissance
plutôt comme une opportunité
c'est cher c'est un projet commun du
collège de france et de l'agencé
française du développement pour essayer
de montrer qu'il est possible de pour le
savoir d'avoir quelque chose à apporter
pour lutter mon mieux contre la pauvreté
parce que cette chère elle s'appelle
savoirs contre pauvreté est ce que ça
veut dire que d'après vous aujourd'hui
quand on lutte contre la pauvreté on
n'associe pas assez justement le savoir
la connaissance de ces milieux on peut
on pourrait lutter au mieux contre la
pauvreté si on associer plus le savoir
différents savoirs d'ailleurs pas
seulement l'économie ça pourrait être la
biologie ça pourra être l'eau mais les
chercheurs le savoir a quelque chose à
dire sur comment lutter au mieux contre
la pauvreté alors justement expliqué
nous un peu votre démarche parce qu'elle
est très particulière vous avez créé un
laboratoire où on my side cambridge là
aussi très prestigieux qu'est ce que
vous faites concrètement
ma démarche est avant tout une démarche
d'évaluation c'est à dire c'est
d'essayer de travailler avec les acteurs
de terrain qui peut être qu'ils peuvent
être des ong qui peuvent être des
gouvernements qui peuvent être des
firmes privées qui essaye de faire des
choses concrètement sur le terrain dans
les pays en développement et d'essayer
de travailler avec eux pour évaluer
l'efficacité de leurs idées et de leurs
programmes
donc en gros ça sert pas à grand chose
si on a de bonnes idées mais qu'elles ne
sont pas efficaces ça veut dire quoi
vous allez sur le terrain vous fait des
évaluations vous regardez les programmes
est-ce que vous avez des exemples de
programmes à nous donner
voilà on va sur le terrain
accompagne l'équipe qui met en place le
projet sur le terrain par exemple si
vous voulez savoir qu'est ce qui est
plus efficace pour que les enfants
apprennent mieux à l'école
est-ce que c'est plus efficace de vous
concentrer sur le soutien scolaire ou
est ce que comme c'est très à la mode
dans beaucoup de pays en développement
est ce qu'il faudrait mettre des
ordinateurs dans les écoles alors pour
savoir la ce qu'il faut faire au sort ce
qu'on peut faire
ce qui coûte le plus cher ce qui est le
mieux les éléments on peut comparer m du
soutien scolaire dans certaines écoles
des ordinateurs dans d'autres écoles
voir les résultats des enfants à la fin
et voir si ça fait une différence
et quel projet est le plus efficace
d'une part et le plus efficace ion par
rapport à ses coûts d'autre part ça vous
l'avez fait concrètement en inde
cette étude la très très particulière
cette évaluation la et les ordinateurs
c'est pas forcément la paix d'accès
alors nous avons eu l'opportunité de
faire en inde parce que justement les
ordinateurs sont très à la mode en inde
et dans une ville de l'inde
la mairie avait distribué le dit avait
décidé de distribuer des ordinateurs
dans toutes les écoles mais ces
ordinateurs rester dans leur boîte sans
être utilisé donc ce que nous avons fait
c'est en travaillant avec une ong dont
d'enlever les ordinateurs des bois dans
la moitié des écoles et dans d'autres
écoles d'envoyer simplement une jeune
femme pour faire du soutien scolaire est
ce qu'on se rend compte c'est que c'est
vrai que les ordinateurs aide les
enfants en particulier
on avait mis dans les ordinateurs des
logiciels de maths est vrai que ça aide
les enfants mais c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup plus cher donc finalement par
rapport à une jeune femme qui se
concentre sur aider les enfants en
difficulté
un ordinateur ça marche pas tellement
mieux
et c'est presque dix fois plus cher donc
finalement se concentrer sur les enfants
en difficulté c'est une stratégie plus
efficace aujourd'hui
alors justement est ce que ça veut dire
que vous qui êtes sur le terrain
régulièrement pour évaluer ses
programmes
vous avez une vision assez critique de
ce que font les ong est ce que vous avez
le sentiment qu'elles répondent vraiment
à des demandes ou que les occidentaux se
font plus plaisir parfois
4 efficace je peux dire que j'ai une
vision critique de ce que font les ong
je crois que c'est formidable d'avoir
des acteurs des idées différentes
essayer des choses ce qui est un petit
peu dommage dans le fourmillement des
ong
c'est que toutes ces idées qui peuvent
être d'ailleurs soient locales soient
venus d'ici et qu'ils sont souvent
locales il ya beaucoup d ong locale
toutes ces idées on n'en tire pas les
leçons
donc on a des tout petits programmes
sans école par 6 5 puis par là sans
vraiment savoir est ce que ça fait une
différence et si on le savait l'impact
de ces ong et du travail quels fonds
pourra être d'autant plus important que
les leçons pour être ensuite incorporés
dans des programmes qui serait fait à
l'échelle d'une nation
l'expérience pourrait être démultipliée
en quelque sorte voilà merci à vous en
tout cas esther duflo donc je rappelle
que vous êtes maintenant professeur au
collège de france et que vous venez de
donner votre leçon inaugurale et on
suivra bien sûr ce que vous faites dans
les programmes de lutte contre la
pauvreté merci encore d'être venu
[Musique]